hello everyone and welcome to round
three of the chancre chess tournament or
the google remove memorial it's again
between david navara and the magnus
carlsen and as you've seen yesterday we
had again between which monitor and
magnus carlsen were on and try to play
into a course in preparation for his
role champ means you match with Fabiana
Caruana and here we have a similar
situation that in navara does the does
something similar and we're gonna get
into that I do hope you enjoyed
yesterday's joke bye bye Dani wrench and
a lot of you seem said in the comments
that you were actually fooled for a few
seconds so I'm very happy it means the
well that's the the job was successful
and if you haven't checked it out
Dani also made an well an impression of
John Bartholomew so I won't put a link
to his video in the description below if
you want to check that out as well
getting back to this game it's navara
versus Casa Navarro has the white pieces
and he opens with E for and since you've
all seen the the World Chess
Championship match between cos and
Fabiano you know that Coulson replies
with c5 the Sicilian defense Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and d4c captures Knight
captures everything the same as in the
match cross and vs. Caruana Knight to f6
with Knight to c3 and now II five the
last great variation or the Pelican
variation whichever you prefer
neither db5 we have these six by cross
and now Knight to d5 we will already
covered all of this when we analyzed
them in games between Carlson and
Caruana Knight captures pawn captures
and here in the in some of the games I
believe in game 8 and 10 calls and
retreated with nice to be eight later he
tried my tstewy 8 I believe in game 12
but all of those games ended in a draw
here across and retreats with nice the
b8 and a four never I just plays
everything the same as was in the game
between Kahlan and Cara wanna yeah we
have a Bishop to e7 Bishop to e2 by
navara with castles by cross and castles
by Navarre and Knight to d7 and this is
where well we have a different move here
in game 8 Carano tried Bishop to d2 with
some ideas of
a five-night - retreated to a tree to c4
and then after this poem captured on f4
cross and play 95 the night went all the
way to b6 and in in game 10 corona tried
that
very nice v4 idea this that was a most
likely my favorite moment and in this
game it's a navara who deviates he plays
king - h1 here first and cross and
immediately pushes the knight back with
a 6/9 to a3 and now there are a couple
of moves that were played in this
position such as f5 and some other moves
but here the move Carlsen played is a
new move in the position he plays a5
which could be an improvement to his
game against Caruana he doesn't allow
white to grab more space with a 5 to
give this night a nice outpost on b6 for
his Knight
so already I moved 13 we have a
completely new game and this is what's
really interesting first unstriped to
play intercourse in spread across a
champion in preparation now Navarro
tries it and well let's see how it goes
but it's although Navarro deviated it's
a 5 this is a new move which most likely
navara was not prepared for but we'll
see what happens we have F for the
similar idea that Caruana employed night
the thief sorry with f5 now by Carlsen
Knight the c4 and b6 now we have rook to
a3 a very nice roof lifts shifting the
rook over to the attack he captures a
knife or with Bishop captures on f4 and
now comes Knight the c5 and excellent
outpost for the night since you will not
be able to kick it away with b4 we've
looked a three an excellent file for the
rook and not cross and goes for g5 seems
like a very risky idea but you know if
it works it works and here you really
have to figure out what to do because
there's a problem if you go something
like rook to g3 crossings gonna go nice
to e4 defend the g5 pawn attack the rook
here once the rook moves you could lose
easily lose the bishop here and then you
could sacrifice the exchange with bush
the three and gained some sort of an
attack but navara decides to give up the
route differently noir plays rook
captures on e7 and now of course you're
not gonna capture here and allow Bishop
captures this would be excellent for
white here instead of cost and place
pawn captures on f4 and now you have a
problem because there's no bishop here
to help out with with the capture on d6
and the rookie doesn't have anywhere to
go here all of these squares are covered
by callsign spawns and the rook is lost
so here you just have to figure out how
to give a give away the rook and never
does it in the best possible way we have
rook to e6 Knight captures on e6 D
captors on e6 and now Bishop captures on
e6 by Carlson and rook captures on f4
with Bishop captures and c4 by Carson
Bishop captures with check King to h8
and now comes g4 so as you can see both
of the Kings are quite quite naked here
and well Carson has what Carson has
going for him is that he is still up the
exchange so Queen to f6 by Carlsen
and now comes c3 just in enforcing the
d4 square not allowing Queen captures on
b2 and here we have Queen to e5 just an
an excellent centralizing square for the
key a queen Queen to f1 now with a
triple attack against the f5 point and
here we have rook 88 navara captures an
f5 with G captures an f5 and now rook to
f6 just blockading that's pawn and now
after Carson you know comes everything
down he will he will be able to enjoy
his his actually he's being up the
exchange with Queen to f2 by Navarro and
now Queen to c5 offering the UH trade of
Queens we have King to g2 defending and
here Queen to c6 check King to H King to
h3 now comes Queen back to c5 and King
back to g2 now our is down the exchange
so he doesn't mind repeating moves and
here calls and decides to go into the
endgame with Queen captures rook
captures sorry rook captures I have to
enter now comes rook to e4 and just
pressuring the bishop if the bishop
moves
you will you will lose the a for pawn
but here Navarro finds a very nice idea
he plays rook the e6 and gives up the e4
pawn cross and grabs that we have rook
captures on a four on a four and now
King to f3 King the g7 we have looked at
d2 going after the d6 pawn and now comes
King to h6 rook captures and d6 by
navara King to g5 and now here you
cannot capture the b6 point if you
capture the b6 pawn then you fall for
rook to f4 check and once the King moves
let's say Kingi - now we get rook
captures on f5 where if you capture you
will be down the exchange but there is
no better move you have to go into this
line or if you don't do anything then
just look to e5 will win the bishop so
here you would have to trade down and
then after Bishop captures here you will
play rook captures here king D 3 and the
now rook captures in h2 you black will
enter this winning game game so that's
one possibility if you capture on b6
Navarre decides that he will not do it
he goes rook to d8 and now rook to h6 by
cousin going after the d h2 pawn
we have rook to GA to check King back to
f6 and not look back the b8 and here
cousin just grabs the pawn rook captures
on h2 we have look after Sun b6 and now
kink the g5 with f6 by white now of
course you cannot capture it if you
capture then well we can just show it if
King captures Bishop e3 tactics of the
rook so that would be winning for white
after f6 we have looked f4 by Carson
checking the King King goes back at the
g3 and now comes rook H 2 F 2 so the
King doesn't really have all that many
squares to go to but on the other hand
if the black king moves then the roofs
are unable to move from the from DF file
as they are guarding each other first
rook to b5 check King captures on f6 and
here Bishop to g4 now the the rooks
cannot leave the F DF file as both of
them are guarding each other we have a
four by Carlsen we have c4 white now
starts pushing this pass pawn here
one such example where you cannot
capture or you would lose the the tf2
rook we have king to g6 and now comes c5
and here here across some place a very
nice idea
the problem with immediately going h5 is
that after after white captures here
which is possible King will capture and
now you get c6 with Czech and now it's a
well it's a very complicated line but
you can easily mess up and and end up
drawing it for example King g6 c7 and
now there is no good way to guard at the
point from queening you would have to go
you can go to something like check and
then here because there's the pawn
blocking the c3 square and then on the
other hand you have to go something like
rope to rope to f8 or or if you give a
check you will go then rope to f8 and
then rook to b8 will will again go in
white favor you will here here here have
to just settle for a perpetual with with
just going back and forth and checking
the white king so after the c5 move
cross and played a three which is a very
nice idea either he will get a passport
that's already on a2 or white has to
well leave control of the c3 square B
captures on a3 is played Navarre grabs
the pawn but now across and can push h5
and now the same idea no longer applies
because now after Bishop captures in h5
there are no complications just King
captures c6 with check King to g6
and now if c7 Carlsen can just play rook
f3 check King has to go to g4 and now
the rook can come to c3 as there is no
pawn here to guard the c3 square and
everything is everything is perfectly
fine Crossing is upper rook the pony's
stopped and Carson will win this game
so after this h5 move we have looked to
be four by navara which ideas that and
okay maybe just to show before going
into this line that instead of this line
if you go something like a bishop to d1
to try and just move the bishop then h4
is the idea a king
to go to h3 then just work the d4 forces
either to capture the bishop or the
other authorities look the d2 followed
by a rook to h2 checkmate and then you'd
have something like a rogue b6 check
King g5 roped a d6 only move if you
don't want a softer look to d3 check
which is even faster which would end
result in checkmate so we'd have to play
something like this but again Rudy - now
you threaten checkmate here and after
white trades you would go
Bishop f3 and now just rugby 3 king
blocks and you will h3 check King - f2
real characters on 83 and you will once
again basically trade down into the same
winning endgame so it's not possible to
capture it's not possible to go Bishop
d1 that's why rook the b4 displayed by
navara and it's a nice idea if you
capture of course then a capture some b4
creates two connected passed pawns and
well you have to move the rook rugby -
now comes the trip to e6 and if you
capture the rook then you have problems
then just c6 and you cannot block the
pawn from behind as the bishop covers
that square so you'd have to go
something like rook the b6 c7 rope here
and then well you would just have to
give up a look and it's it's a draw
so after this rook to be form of course
and of course did not capture call
simply look to f8 and here we have
Bishop to d1 now look to d2 by Carlsen
Bishop back to f3 and now comes Luke to
d3
attacking the a3 pawn and now comes
looked f4 again a warning to trade rooks
but here crossing just quick and see the
advancement of his H pawn h4 check
you cannot capture of course as you're
going to lose the rook and if rook
captures then both of the rooks are
smashing down on that version of on f3
so King the g4 now we have looked
captures an F for King captures on f4
and rook captures on a3 so it's a
similar line as the one that never I was
able to avoid but he he had no choice he
had to trade down into it
we have c6 and here you can see that the
light square bishop is quite excellent
controlling the c6 pawn and also
controlling the queening square so not
not not all that bad but
the deposition is completely winning for
black and Carlsen knows it we have rook
to c3
Bishop to d5 and now h3 we have kinky
five and now h2 is is a very nice move
but there is a better move so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the move that is much better than h2 as
it winds much quicker I'll give you a
couple of seconds for you to decide
whether you want to do it or not well I
have a nicely put my water for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
endgame player and a quick one at that
and for those you who just want to enjoy
a show instead of h2 immediately first
rook the c5 it's it's just over so here
whatever you play doesn't really matter
in the game of Navarre play King to d6
and now the move you also had to find if
you found rook to c5 is rook captures on
d5 but it's it's really it's I mean it's
just a poetic it's almost poetic how
Carlson does it instead of this h2 line
because now after King captures cross
and played h2 and of course you don't
gain anything by advancing the pawn
because Carlsen brings a queen into the
game with check and it's very
interesting because a C pawn is often
drawn if if the White King can reach the
corner but in this case it's not of
course calls and saw it and he decided
that it was winning here never played
the King to d4 just not allowing costant
to bring the Queen into the game with
check but as he played before he also
resigned to the game what if you resign
well it's it's completely winning but to
show you why it's completely winning
before our first show you why it's
winning after you place these seven
let's say queen h1 check and I have to
move the King and now you get Queen to
be 7 just not allowing the pawn the
Queen and after you prepare it kink the
b7 now you get King to f7 King to d8 and
now of course you get Queen to b6 you
pin the pawn and the King doesn't really
have anywhere to go you can either go
behind the pawn which then the black
king takes this opportunity well not
there obviously but take this
opportunity to come closer to the pawn
or you will go here and then it's just
force checkmate you'll go Queens it's
checking the eight and Queenie 8 will be
checkmate but I will also show for those
who are perhaps new to chess
why if if white is able to bring the
King all the way to the corner it's a
draw we already mentioned this plenty of
times the a pawn the C pawn the F pawn
and the H pawn can be drawn even if even
if you just have a pawn in your opponent
has a king for example will show one
such line for example Queen each one
check King to d6 and now let's say let's
say black plays a couple of silly moves
out let's say he go he drew he tries
something like Queen 2h to check let's
try a couple of checks here for some
reason let's say black does this and
then you go something like here to
prevent the pawn black will go here you
will play check and now from the White
King will not go into the corner and
allow the black King to come closer but
white will just go to the corner play
King to a eight and now black has no
moves I mean he does but either white
will bring the Queen into the game or
black will finally captured upon but now
it's stalemate so it's a draw but yeah
it's it's similar what like I said da
pond the C pawn the f1 and the H pawn
which you can also test out for
ourselves if you're interested in you
know sure to show your friends in in the
bar or in the library but yeah after
King to d4 Navarro resigned the game and
yet another victory for Magnus Carlsen
in a row in the Indigo Jima memorial so
it's two for two first on and tried the
Coronas preparation against arsenal
Navarro tried caranas preparation
against Carlsen
and it simply doesn't work which I'm I'm
not surprised I mean it shouldn't work
Carlson had he had months to prepare for
everything and well I would say that he
knows these lines are better better than
anyone else but yeah we'll see it's it's
a long tournament people will try more
and I guess I guess you know they will
also try
kuranes preparation against it but we'll
see how it goes so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it we will not be
showing the standing says I will most
likely be showing another game from
round three of the game of Memorial I
think
maybe Island versus Mahmoud er Ava's
they have finished their game yeah I
would like to think Alan ferns Michael
Hildebrand Paul staples managed bean
well and research solely for our
contribution to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos serie think
all for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and if you are interested in the
lines that were mentioned in this game I
will also put a link to game eight and
ten between Carson Caruana from the
World Chess Championship match if you
just want to check that out as well so
thank you all and I will see you soon